FRED SAUER: The rate at which
you can write the same entity
group is limited to one entity
group of write per second.
And that seems, the developers
writing it, that
seems really low.
They were imagining a Facebook
application with 200,000 daily
active users, which means
something like 20,000
concurrent users on peak.
So they're kind of contrasting
this and saying, well, on the
one hand, I have 20,000
concurrent users all making
requests at the very same
moment, and you're telling me
one per second?
Where is the disconnect?
MANDY WAITE: I think it depends
on what your entity
group was actually developed
to represent and how
extensively you've modeled
it and the way you've
modeled your data.
If your entity group is really
specific to the particular
user that's making the call,
then you won't really have to
worry about it.
One write per second would
be perfectly adequate.
But if you kind of sprawled it
a bit and the entity group
touches multiple users, then
you're likely to have some
contention on that
entity group.
And so you have multiple
users banging away at
it at the same time.
But really, it's best practices
at modeling your
entities that will actually
avoid that kind of issue.
So if you have 20,000 concurrent
requests, you're
likely to be accessing 20,000
different entity groups and
might have an issue.
FRED SAUER: And that
should be fine.
If you want to do 2 million
concurrent users on 2 million
different entity groups,
that's absolutely fine.
MANDY WAITE: Absolutely.
FRED SAUER: To think about
entity groups as for the most
part your unit of
transactionality.
MANDY WAITE: Yeah.
FRED SAUER: So if you need some
data related to a given
user, like a user and their
achievements, for example, and
you have those stored in three
or four different entities,
you can put them all in one
entity group, and then the App
Engine Datastore will make sure
that you can only have
one transaction in flight at a
time for that entity group.
So generally, what we see is
that each user becomes an
entity group or each order in an
order entry system, or each
customer in a CRM system becomes
an entity group.
We actually also have, we didn't
have this initially,
but we introduced this again
about a year ago, something
called cross-entity group
transactions or XG
transactions.
And that allows you to transact
up to five different
entity groups in a single
transaction.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, OK.
That's awesome.
FRED SAUER: So it used to be the
case that before we had XG
transactions, there was a little
bit of this trade off
between, I want to make my
entity groups bigger because I
want to do transactions, but I
need to make them smaller and
have the right throughput.
And that was sometimes
a challenge.
There were, in fact, libraries
that sprung up that tried to
figure out how to--
the classic example is, I
have two bank accounts.
I want to move $10 from
this bank account
to that bank account.
I need to do that within
a transaction.
And if I deduct $10 here and
then add $10 there and
something goes wrong
in the middle,
the $10 would disappear.
Or if I add $10 first and then
remove $10, I've created $10
out of nothing.
MANDY WAITE: Oh, I
like that one.
FRED SAUER: Well, let's
do that one.
With cross-entity group
transactions,
that's no longer a problem.
You can actually, in a single
transaction, make that change.
So really, I think this is all
about just structuring your
datastore in such a way that you
do no more than one write
per second.
Another kind of classic way that
people run into this is
they'll do something like
they'll create a site counter.
They want to know how many
visitors came to the website.
MANDY WAITE: Exactly.
FRED SAUER: Favorite
example, right?
And so every time a user comes
into the website, they
increment the counter.
And this is what you would
do in a SQL database.
You would kind of increment a
particular row in the datastore.
And the problem is only one
person at a time can update
that one record because that
one record is on disk
somewhere and there's some
server responsible for it, and
it can only touch that record
one transaction at a time.
And that's really limiting
for the number of
things you can count.
And so a typical strategy that
you used for the App Engine
Datastore is to create something
called a sharding
counter, sharded counter,
where you partition the
counter into multiple
counters.
So instead of say 1 counter, you
split it out and you say,
OK, let's make 5 counters or
50, some number end that's
configurable.
And now, every time someone
comes to the website, I'm
going to at random pick a number
from one to five and
then I'm going to update
that counter.
So let's say it's counter
three this time.
The next visitor comes in, oh,
it's again counter three.
Oh, now, it's counter two.
And you say, well, that's weird
because now your total
page view count is
split up around
five different counters.
But that's not a big deal,
because you can easily select
five numbers and add
them together.
This is a very easy task
for a computer to do.
But by doing so, you've just
increased the throughput of
your web counter five-fold.
If you need 50 transactions per
second, you go 50 fold,
plus a little bit buffer,
so maybe you go 60,
something like that.
But it's very easy to shard your
counter out as far as you
need to go.
MANDY WAITE: And there's
actually examples on the
website, isn't there?
FRED SAUER: Yeah, it's
our article.
MANDY WAITE: In the development
documentation.
FRED SAUER: Yep.
So with a little bit of data
modeling, you can do as many
concurrent users as you like.
And hopefully you do a
lot more than 20,000.
But 20,000 is pretty awesome.
I wish my website had--
MANDY WAITE: 20,000
is pretty good.
Yeah.
Well, I guess the message
here really is avoid
shared mutable state.
I love shared mutable
state all the same.
Every time you share a state
that's mutable, you're going
to run into problems
with concurrency.
So just keep it isolated.
FRED SAUER: If you do
that, you're going
to have a bad time.
MANDY WAITE: You're going
Absolutely.